le fait de démonter la tente c'est aussi
pour mettre un coup de pression aux
enfants et montrer ben voilà à cause de
vous on s'en va c'est votre faute si
vous ne serez pas comme ça on serait
resté on aurait petit déjeuner qui fait
mais on n'a pas envie de rester moi je
veux partir là je veux rentrer chez moi
je veux disparaître de ce camping
70% des femmes se disent fatigués à leur
retour et même stressés pour 53% d'entre
elles en cause l'inégale répartition des
tâches domestiques qui elles ne prend
pas de vacances Les Marmottes se
nourrissent principalement de végétaux
et chacune à son coin d'herbe préféré
les petits doivent apprendre à défendre
le leur
[Musique]
tandis qu'ils font l'apprentissage de la
vie leur mère veille sur eux et leur
père économisent son énergie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on pleure sur tous les temps mon cœur je
voudrais aller faire un petit peu
il faut que je t'installe la cabine et
tout
tu sais finalement regarde
la cabine de douche sert aussi de
cabinet de toilette mais aujourd'hui pas
besoin de se cacher mais c'est
tranquille
c'est la meilleure vue qui soit seul
progrès les hommes semblent avoir
davantage conscience de ces inégalités
49% à vous être plus reposé que leur
conjointes quand ils sont dans des
modèles de comparaison avec le passé
considère qu'ils en font beaucoup plus
mais quand on compare point par point la
répartition des tâches domestiques et
parentales à chaque fois ou presque ce
sont les femmes qui en font plus ou
beaucoup plus et les clichés la vie dure
les hommes restent largement plus
impliqués dans deux domaines la conduite
du véhicule familial et la gestion du
barbecue ici le choix devient délimité
car les Indiens sont en majorité
végétarien et la vache est un animal
sacré
c'est soit de l'industriel et j'ai pas
très confiance ici au moins c'est
qualité fraîcheur
de la fraîcheur c'est sûr mais pour
l'hygiène les normes ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes qu'en France
la découpe du poulet se fait avec les
pieds
la recette le bec est rose
ce que ça veut dire qu'il est amoureux
effectivement je suis Laurette la saison
des amours est à son apogée
les femelles ça c'est la parade
amoureuse c'est le seul bruit qu'à fond
elles écartent les ailes et attaque du
bec
[Musique]
d'accord pour prendre
entre chat
tête en avant
battement d'aile
c'est tendance sans cette chorégraphie
si délicate que sa fille s'unira un jour
un partenaire pour la vie
tu sais si le mariage c'est symbolique
il y a beaucoup
sûr
[Musique]
funéraire et ensuite je suis sortie donc
de la mort pour retourner à mon fourgon
funéraire évidemment et bah là j'ai vu
un très bel homme et je l'ai regardé
évidemment il était vivant oui c'est lui
a été vivant
salut Nico ça va
[Musique]
et là bon bah je l'appelle Nico Nico
Nico
[Musique]
je vois qu'on s'est compris nous avons
quatre fils
qui a 34 ans
18 ans et Anatole 14 ans sans oublier un
autre membre de la famille
donc on a notre fille quand même
parce que comme on a pas réussi à avoir
des filles on a pris une chaîne quoi
perdue Nico là
[Musique]
tu m'entends
si quelque chose ne me fait pas plaisir
au mieux je le fais pas au pire je le
fais mal donc j'ai besoin que ça me
plaise voir que ça m'obsède si ça me
plaît je suis très bon si ça m'obsède je
suis excellent je suis un obsédé
Faustine
est-ce qu'on peut isoler cette phrase
parce qu'on pourrait la coller à plein
de thèmes
agitent de plus en plus leur queue il
devient clair qu'aucun des deux ne
cédera le combat est inévitable
[Musique]
le rituel consiste à s'immerger trois
fois de suite dans cet eau sacrée bien
qu’extrêmement pollué
3 milliards de litres d'eau usées si
déverses chaque jour la concentration en
matière fécales y est 66 fois plus forte
que le niveau autorisé pour la baignade
des chercheurs américains assurent la
pollution atmosphérique c'est la
première des menaces et pour cause
Anne-Sophie parce que
99% de la population de la planète
respirent un air pollué alors évidemment
cette nouvelle étude montre que ça a des
conséquences il y a une perte pour
chacun d'entre nous d'espérance de vie
qui ait évaluée à deux années alors
c'est devant l'alcool c'est devant le
tabac sauf dans certains pays comme la
France
[Musique]
elle est purifiée voilà moi je préfère
rester un pur allez complètement dingue
je la touche pas pendant je ne sais pas
combien de temps il va falloir un
certificat médical là un verre vivant et
se tortillon a été découvert dans le
cerveau d'une australienne qui souffrait
de troubles de la mémoire c'est la
première fois que ce parasite a dit des
kangourous et des pythons et découvert
sur un être humain à l'australienne
pourrait avoir été parasitée par des
plantes comestibles contaminées par des
larves
toute l'équipe a décidé
[Applaudissements]
on a dit qu'on en voulait pas pour ne
pas ce jeu